welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're going
back to the
[Music]
thing I've just done a big breakdown of
the 2011 prequel and obviously I had to
immediately put on the original because
of how that film ends upon me watching
it I noticed some details I'd never seen
before and hopefully this video makes
you appreciate the movie even more this
scent is around Charles and mccre stuck
in the snow without post 31 on fire
around them both are doomed to die but
the big question remains is Charles the
thing there's been a ton of theories
about how mccre gave Charles kerosene or
petrol to drink and the thing not
noticing this is what gives it away
honestly I've always just thought that's
more of a popular Theory but there's not
actually any basis for it in the film
none of the creative team have ever said
that's the case and there's actually a
moment before the drink which debunks
the entire thing just before Charles
comes walking over we can see mccre p
the bottle out and almost go to drink it
at this point he had no idea that
Charles was there and a doubt man was
sitting down to willingly drink petrol
so that's debunked unless you guys think
you wanted to drink petrol and instead I
think we should look at an earlier scene
to see the subtext that Carpenter was
giving us to Telegraph the answer in
order to do this let's go back to when
we first met mccre as there's a lot of
similarities to what happens at the end
in the scene we catch him playing a game
of chess against a computer which he
refers to as
Che this is because it pulls off
an impossible move and uses this to win
in order to beat him the computer itself
is a metaphor for the thing which Cheats
by imitating humans and pretending to be
them now what else is mccre doing in
this scene well he sat back holding a
drink and we can see that this comes
from a bottle of j& B this is something
he sips during the scene in which he
talks about the torn clothing drawing
attention to it as he learns something
new it's also something that he ends up
giving to Benning after he shot and
they're scrambling about to see what's
going on the bottle appears throughout
the film and on this watch through it's
stuck out like a sore thumb now when we
car to the end and see what Charles is
drinking you can catch the exact same
label on the bottle this shows they're
one and the same and I think the
beginning in and M each other to spell
out the true meaning mccre ends up
tipping the glass into the computer to
break it and symbolically this is him
catching it out at a level it comp
playet this J&B appearing in the final
scene also shows how mccre is catching
out the thing just in the same way he
gave it to the computer he's now giving
it to Charles as a way to determine the
truth it's something he has when he
learns something about an opponent and
thus I think its usage signifies that
now Charles and all the other people at
the camp they would be well aware about
the rules around sharing food and drink
they' know for a fact that you're not
supposed to do it as it is a way the
thing can spread and take over your body
the fact that Charles does adere shows
he's clearly not worried because if
you're the thing then you can't catch
the thing it's this clear disregard that
gives away its position and I believe
it's why mccre laughs when he takes a
drink he's caught him out in this game
like he caught out the computer and
can't be fooled by the cheating the
thing carrying out there's also the fact
that Charles's attitude has changed and
he's a lot calmer in the scene than
what's come before going back through
the film I actually noticed lots of in
is where the personalities of characters
changed who will later reveal to be the
thing for example Blair has a breakdown
he smashes The Outpost like it's the
like button destroying all the radios
and ways they can get out he's locked up
in the Hut outside which the group later
visit but here he's far more withdrawn
than what's come before in this shot we
can see a noose hanging up potentially
showing what the real Blair was planning
to get up to instead I think that he was
taken over at some point and the coma
version we see here is indeed the alien
now if you don't agree with this then I
think you need to think about Blair and
what he's acted like in the rest of the
movie Blair is someone who discovered
how quickly the thing could assimilate
and he even ran simulations to show how
fast it would wipe out Humanity here
though Blair is like I don't want to
stay out here anymore I want to come
back inside now I personally right I
personally don't think Blair would want
to go back to the group at all as he'd
be far more likely to be assimilated by
the thing instead I think he's the thing
at this point and he knows going back to
the group will give him opportunities
this will allow the thing to then
assimilate the rest and he's trying to
win mcc's trust so he lets him go back
now another thing that has a big change
is Palmer who starts off as a loud mouth
and hotthead in the group child chariots
to the gods man they practically own
South America however we see Palmer get
karma and hide in the back of the group
instead of drawing attention to himself
keeping an eye on who the thing was
unnoticed it tend to go more for the
outcast characters and hide in the
background instead of being the bigger
names Norris yeah not really a
confrontational or person that panics he
just hangs in the back completely out
the way Pal's an outcast that isn't
really trusted and in the end no one
really wants to work with him wondering
when El capan was going to get a chance
to use his pop gun doc I'll give
you the lift no problem forget it
P hey thanks for thinking about it do BL
get sent outed in the H and we also know
a triy to imitate fukes he also wasn't
really one of the people who got
involved in the arguments and was kind
of a Meek personality who could just
hang out the way the way Charles comes
across here is different to how he's
been and to me seems far more docile and
trusting of mccre put yourself in this
position though would you accept the
drink fully aware that this person could
be contaminated now I wouldn't and I get
they probably know that they're going to
die but yeah I don't think I would be as
trusting as he was again like I said
said if he knows he's a thing though
then he wouldn't have this worry and
would just go ahead with it now the
theme for the creature also comes in at
this point and spells out exactly why
child is the
thing anyway if you're enjoying the
video then please hit the thumbs up
Buton actually do it this time and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every week now another big question
of the film comes early on when trying
to decipher who the first person was
that the thing assimilated whether
intentional or not I kind of love how
the dog aggressively licked benning's
face when it believes it's going to die
and this is a desperate attempt for it
to quickly pass on itself cells we see
it completely calm down once lws has
taken over though and its attitude's
different because it's no longer in
danger now from this point we watch it
walk about the base and then strut into
a room where we see a person Shadows
turning round which is the first
character it imitates and this Shadow
doesn't act actually belonged to anyone
in the cast and Carpenter actually used
an extra in order to create the effect
it's deliberately meant to look like
either noris a Palmer because this would
make us confused about who it really was
as we know though both of these become
the thing but I think we can determine
which one of these was first that's
because during the night of the dog
attack we see something with Palmer that
does give it away at about the 26 26
Mark he shares a joint with Charles
which would be enough to then infect him
Charles pass the blood test wereas
Palmer doesen showing that at this point
he was at least Still Human now I also
thought about how the snow closes in on
the camp and in many ways it's like how
the thing assimilates cells the weather
takes over and then covers the location
rendering a partt of the environment now
in which it's all consumed might be a
reach but just something I thought was
symbolic and a nice idea that continues
on the assimilation now all this talk
about the ending made me look a little
deeper into it and uncover all the ones
that Carpenter originally had there were
several ideas with one involving the dog
surviving the explosion and looking at
the destroyed Camp before running off
into the snow another that was filmed
but was never shown to audiences had
mccreedy getting rescued and taken back
to civilization here he took a blood
test with a mysterious government agent
seeming to say that he knew what the
thing was it was also an ending where
Charles and mccre turned on each other
and the pair fought to the death due to
their paranoia ultimately this was
scrapped in the favor of ambiguity and I
think the thing strongest aspect is its
nihilistic ending in the end the movie
is an incredible piece of film and it's
crazy to think it's over 40 years old
goes to show just how good it is when
we're still talking about it now and
picking it apart all this time later I
really don't think there's that many
movies now we'll be talking about in 4
the years's time and yeah just have fans
out this like me just constantly
discussing it it shows the impact that
this movie's really had now I really
hope you enjoy the thoughts I put across
and hopefully it makes you view the film
in a brand new light please drop a like
on the video and if you want to support
the channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week we've also started doing
audio versions so you get that even
before we've started the edit and if you
want to listen to it like a podcast that
that's completely up to you if you want
to get some heavy spoilers merch we've
also got our t-shirt line located below
the video and this will let you pick up
all kinds of tops like our Theory time
one house of the Dragon stuff Marvel
te's and a lot more we dropped new
design on there all the time like the
let's get naughty one so yeah keep an
eye out for them and huge thank you if
you bought one now if you want something
else to watch you've got a breakdown of
the 2011 thing on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this either the way huge thank you for
sing through the video I'll be in Paul
I'll see you next time take care peace